[Musique]
tu es un clown habillé comme hitler dans
le cheval
ce n'est pas hitler c'est chaplin et je suis un
acteur
à la suite de l'invasion allemande le
it français un orphelin juif mes parents
ont été tués par des nazis
tu vas  recevoir 50 à 100 de
nos amis par mois,
aucun endroit n'est sûr pour eux dans un
pays occupé par des nazis,
vous devez les entraîner à survivre maintenant,
l'astuce consiste à vous assurer
que même s'ils voient ce qu'ils voient,
ils  attention
lassell
je ne veux pas continuer à courir sans
faire quelque chose il y a un groupe
à lyon qui s'arme pour se défendre
à propos de la suisse
tu prévois de prendre de la gélatine sur des
eaux couvertes de neige